very high on Caleb Williams but USC just
lost her second game in a row to Utah a
lot of critics say he doesn't perform
well against top opponents I just think
that's BS doesn't matter how many points
you put up and how well you play if your
defense cannot get stops if they cannot
create turnover create opportunities
very well hurt your success you hear
people on line saying he should just get
ready for the NFL I never agree and
before people say anything yes I opted
out and it still hauns me to this day
there's things I wanted to accomplish
still left in my career but their season
is not over right would you start you
finish regardless of circumstances you
have a chance to pick your team up and
continue the season and show them why
you are who you are don't give up on
your dreams don't give up on your team I
would love to see them stay in
college